[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Виноградівка,
Бессарабія]
[Гагаузи — православний тюркомовний народ, нащадки кочових племен огузів.]
[Українські гагаузи компактно мешкають в селах та містах Бессарабії (Буджак)]
[Сьогодні святкування одного із головних свят цього народу — Хедерлезу,]
[поєднує в собі язичницькі, ісламські та християнські елементи]
[несе тушу ягнати]
От і все.
Щасти вам! Усіх благ вам!
Бажаю поповнення! Щоб наступного року приплід був хороший!
— Так
— Чекаємо на новий врожай
На жаль немає дощу. Слабенький (врожай)
На жаль вже дуже давно не було дощу і тому ці питання трохи складно вирішити.
— Після цього свята може й піде дощ.
— Може й піде.
Зазвичай так, всі ці жертвоприношення також і для того,
щоб бог змилувався і дав дощ.
І обов’язково, одна з найкращих прикмет на День святого Георгія — це коли йде дощ.
[складають тарілки]
Гагаузи (їхні пращури — огузи) переселилися сюди десь з 1805–1806 рр.,
коли було перше переселення з Болгарії,
[Ольга Кулаксиз
директорка Центру гагаузької культури]
з Балкан.
Гагаузи — це православний народ.
Якщо навіть наша мова…От ми відносимося до тюркської групи.
Серед тюркської групи, скажімо, є чимало мусульман.
Але є і православні.
От гагаузи, знаючи гагаузьку мову,
вони православні.
На підвіконні, як виходите — все там, на підвіконні.
Дівчата, дайте мені рибу.
Так це не робиться.
Все, посуд готовий.
Це чиста (миска) для моєї риби.
Ось так.
Ні, навпаки: це моя, з оцтом.
Ага, даєш?
Це свято символізує молодого баранця,
особливо ягня.
Його печуть на ось такому вогнищі.
Взагалі у нас село розділене на дві частини.
У давні часи була одна частина — гагаузів,
інша частина — болгар.
[Катерина Божева
кухарка]
Навіть хлопці так і ділилися на дві сторони:
була махала гагаузька і махала болгарська.
І хлопці не ділили дівчат.
Між ними була ворожнеча.
У Болгарії кажуть «булка» — це жінка, дружина.
— Булка — це дружина.
— Дружина, саме дружина
Наші болгари «булка» називають наречену
Ну так, але в роки війни наші солдати в Болгарії казали:
«Можна нам одну булку?» в магазині. Мали на увазі булку хліба. І переплутали.
Хедерлез — це одне з великих — скажімо, найвищого рівня — гагаузьких свят,
яке гагаузи шанують так само, як Великдень.
Чому саме День с  вятого Георгія,
бо святий Георгій — це покровитель малої та великої рогатої худоби.
Хедерлез — це свято першої роси,
першого приплоду, перших квітів, всього першого.
За традицією,
в День святого Георгія, тобто 6 травня,
жінки йшли до колодязя, набирали першу воду.
Намагалися першими набрати воду.
Цією водою вони вмивалися, аби бути здоровими і красивими.
[гагаузькою]
Доброго ранку, господине!
Називається «булгур курбан».
Курбан — бо м’ясне жертовне, жертовного ягняти,
а булгур — бо сама крупа називається у нас булгур.
Все це випікається і виходить «курбан булгур», ось така цікава страва.
Значить десь півтора, скажімо, так?
Дві баночки
Ага, два кілограма крупи, додається літр рослинної олії,
шматочки м’яса,
сіль вже за смаком і чорний перець,
лавровий лист обов’язково.
Є у нас хороша цікава страва —
червоний гіркий товчений перець.
Але його сюди не кладуть,
аби зберегти колір такий, яким він є
у натуральному вигляді.
Все, вистачить стільки, так?
[слухає пташиний спів]
Домнікія — кухарка й пекарка,
а от Надія Харлампієвна — друга помічниця —
вона колишня акушерка, медпрацівниця.
Коли проводимо такі масштабні, всесільські заходи,
то не зважаючи на свою основну діяльність,
не зважаючи на заняття —
всі гагаузькі господині володіють навичками приготування національних страв
і їх застосовують і показують, використовують їх.
Все, дівчата
[гагаузькою]
І мені так здається.
Може треба його поділити? Цей надто великий.
[гагаузькою]
Не вміститься по висоті. Надто високий
Візьміть якийсь менший
[гагаузькою]
А чи вміститься?
Наша мова відноситься до тюркської мовної групи.
Найбільш схожа — турецька мова.
Але гагаузи зберегли давньотюркську мову.
Гагаузька мова — це давньотюркська мова.
Це перші книги в Україні з вивчення гагаузької мови.
А коли ми тільки почали вивчати гагаузьку мову, то я створила…
Я працюю вчителькою і у нас завжди були конкурси — педагогічні аукціони.
І ось на цей педагогічний аукціон кожен вчитель мав право підготувати методичні матеріали,
присвячені тому передмету, який йому до вподоби.
І ось я, всією душею люблячи нашу рідну гагаузьку мову,
зібрала такий цікавий матеріал і назвала його «Весела абетка».
З першого класу цього року все навчання ведеться українською мовою.
Вивчають гагаузьку, російську, українську та англійську мови.
З п’ятого класу також викладають французьку мову,
тобто вивчають ще одну європейську мову.
Починаючи із п’ятого класу частина дітей продовжує вивчати гагаузьку мову,
а інша частина — вчить французьку.
Ходімо сюди
От, дзвінок з уроку.
Дзвінок з уроку
Гагаузьку мову в Болградському районі вивчають в чотирьох селах:
Дмитрівка, Олександрівка, Кубей і Виноградівка.
В Кілійському районі є село Старі Трояни,
де також по повній програмі вивчають гагаузьку мову.
І в Ренійському районі — в селі Котловина.
Ясна річ, вони проводять і позакласні заходи.
[Євгенія Кишлали
вчителька]
Так, у нас от нещодавно був позакласний захід «Традиційна гагаузька кухня».
На столах було велике розмаїття гагаузьких страв
і кожна дитинка розповідала про свою страву.
[гагаузькою]  Коврєк, гьозлємє, киирма,
[гагаузькою]
дизмана, кабакли, мамаліга, йурт, cютляч, пейнір.
Ну і була каурма, але я її чомусь не сфотографувала.
Все. Дякую!
— Ну каурма…
— Каурма теж була, так
Може ми завтра побачимо каурму
Ми себе вважаємо громадянами України.
Україна — наша батьківщина, розумієте?
Просто ми — гагаузького походження.
Але ми українці.
Наша батьківщина — Україна.
[Автор проекту: Богдан Логвиненко
Продюсерка: Ольга Шор]
[Режисер:
Микола Носок]
[Оператори:
Марія Теребус, Микола Носок]
[Субтитри:
Євгенія Сапожникова]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Відео створене за підтримки USAID]